in the last video we talked about
exponentially weighted averages this
will turn out to be a key component of
several optimization algorithms that you
use to train your neural networks so in
this video I want to delve a little bit
deeper into intuitions for what this
algorithm is really doing recall that
distance the key equation for
implementing exponentially weighted
averages and so it beta equals 0.9
you've got the red line if it was much
closer to 1 it was 0.98 you get the
green line and it is much smaller we use
0.5 you get the yellow line let's look
at a bit more than math to understand
how this is computing averages of the
DVD temperature so here's that equation
again and let's set beta equals 0.9 and
write tell a few equations that
discourse ponds - so whereas when is
menteng it you'd have T going from 0 to
1 to 2 to 3 increasing values of T to
analyze it I've written it with
decreasing values of T all right and
this goes on so let's take this first
equation here and understand what v100
really is so V 100 is going to be let me
reverse these two terms so it's going to
be 0.1 times theta 100 plus 0.9 times
whatever the value was on the previous
day now for what is V 99 well we just
plug it in from this equation so this is
just going to be 0.1 times theta 99 and
again up reverse on these two terms
alright plus 0.9 times V 98 but then
what is V 98 well you just get back from
here so you can just plug in here 0.1
times K 298 plus 0.9 times B 97 and so
on and if you multiply all of these
terms out you can show that V 100 is 0.1
times theta 100 plus now let's look at
professional on theta 99 is going to be
0.1 times 0.9 times theta 99 now let's
look at the coefficient on
ninety-eight there's a 0.1 here times
0.9 times 0.9 so if you expand out the
algebra this becomes 0.1 times 0.9
squared times theta 98 and if you keep
expanding this out you find that this
becomes 0.1 times 0.9 cubed theta 97
plus 0.1 times 0.9 to the fourth times
theta 96 plus dot dot dot so this is
really a weighted sum does a weighted
average of theta 100 which is the
current day's temperature we're looking
for a perspective of V 100 which you
calculate on the 100th day of the year
but those are some of you know theta 180
99 1398 397 beta 96 and so on so one way
to draw this in pictures would be if um
let's say we have some number of days of
temperature so this is Theta and this is
T right so theta 100 would be some value
then say 299 where some value of theta
98 so these are you know so this is T
equals 100 99 98 and so on right so you
have some number of days of temperature
and what we have is then an
exponentially decaying function so
starting from zero point one to zero
point nine times 0.1 to 0.9 squared
times zero point one two and so on so
you have this exponentially decaying
function and the way you compute the 100
is you take the element wise product
between these two functions and sum it
up so you take this value theta one
hundred times zero point one times this
value of theta
99 times zero point one times zero point
nine that's the second term and so on so
it's really taking the daily temperature
multiplying with this explanation
decaying function and then summing it up
and this becomes your be 100 it turns
out that up the details are talked about
later but all of these coefficients add
up to
one or adults are very close to one up
to a detail called bias correction which
talked about in this video but because
the dad does really is an exponentially
weighted average and finally you might
wonder you know how many dairies
temperature is this averaging over well
it turns out that 0.9 right to the power
of 10 is about 0.35 and this turns out
to be about one over e one of the bases
of lot of natural logarithms and more
generally if you have one minus Epsilon
so in this example epsilon would be zero
point one so if this is zero point nine
then 1 minus epsilon to the one over
epsilon this is about one over e is
about 0.3 for 0.35 and so in other words
it takes about ten days for the height
of this to decay to you know around
one-third and already one over e of the
peak so it's because of this that when
beta equals 0.9 we say that it takes
this is as if you're computing and
exponentially weighted average that
focuses on just the last 10 days
temperature because it sort of after 10
days that the weight the case to you
know less than about a third of the
weight of the current day whereas in
contrast if beta was equal to 0.98 then
well what do you need Oh point nine
eight to the power of in order for this
to be really small turns out that 0.98
to the power of 50 will be approximately
equal to one over e so the way to be
pretty big will be bigger than one over
e for the first 50 days and then they'll
you know dictate quite rapidly over that
so intuitively this is a hard-line
fasting you can think of business
averaging over about 50 days temperature
because in this example to use the
notations here on the left it's as if
epsilon is equal to 0.02 so 1 over
epsilon is 50 and this by the way is how
we call the formula that we're averaging
over 1 over 1 minus beta also days right
here epsilon we
replace the row of 1 minus beta it tells
you up to some constant roughly how many
days temperatures you think if this is
averaging over but this is just a rule
of thumb for how to think about it and
is in a formal mathematical statement
finally let's talk about how you
actually implement this recall that we
start over B 0 initializes 0 then
compute B 1 on the first day B 2 and so
on now to explain the algorithm it was
useful to write down v-0 v1 v2 and so on
as distinct variables but if you're
implementing this in practice is
question 2 is you initialize V to be
equal to 0 and then on day one you would
set V equals beta times B plus 1 minus
beta times theta one and then on the
next day you would update V to be equal
to beta on B plus 1 minus beta theta 2
and so on and I'm sometimes use this
notation B subscript theta to denote
that D is computing this exponentially
weighted average of the parameters theta
so just to say this again but a for-loop
format you set V theta equals 0 and then
repeatedly to live on each day you would
get mixed say 2t and then sets B theta
gives updated as beta times the old
value of B theta plus 1 minus beta you
know times the current value of V theta
so one of the advantages of this
exponential weighted average formula is
that it takes very little memory you
just need to keep you know this one row
number in computer memory and you keep
on overwriting it with what this formula
based on the latest value that you got
and it's really this reason the
efficiency it just takes you know one
line of code basically and just storage
a memory for a single real number to
compute this exponentially weighted
average there's really not the best way
but not the most accurate way to compute
an average if you were to compute a
moving window where you explicitly sum
over the last 10 days a lot of 30 days
temperature and just divide by ten or
divide by 50 that usually gives you a
better estimate but a disadvantage of
that of explicitly keeping all the
temperatures around in some of the last
10 days is requires more memory and it's
just more complicated implementing this
computationally more expensive so for
things we'll see some examples in next
few videos where you need to compute
averages of a lot of variables this is a
very efficient way to do so both from a
computation and memory efficiency point
of view which is why it's used a lot in
machine learning not to mention that is
just one line of code which is maybe
another advantage so now you know how to
implement exponentially weighted
averages there's one more technical
detail that's what if you're doing about
bias correction let's see that in the
next video and then after that you
really use this to build a better
optimization algorithm than the
straightforward gradient descent